well I think this is something that  those of us who are not Europeans are  trying to watch on the one hand you run  into more and more Europeans who  consider themselves not just from their  particular nation state but also as  parts of a larger Europe they're used to  this in terms of their travel they're  used to this in terms of their money  they're used to in terms of their jobs  and economics but the tensions have  heightened some of the old nationalist  feelings so Greeks under stress point to  Germany's terrible actions in World War  two some other countries that are  feeling the pressure of immigration at  the same time are turning against others  so there's the danger in any economic  downturn of populous and nationalists  tendencies  you